[Music]
team biden is giving the taliban the
benefit of the doubt caving to the
terror group's demands that all u.s
troops be out in a week and trusting
that the militants will fully cooperate
with ongoing evacuations
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport thus far
the taliban have been taking steps to
work with us so we can get our people
out there's a reality that the taliban
is currently controlling large swaths of
afghanistan the taliban have made public
and private commitments to provide and
permit safe passage for americans it's
been important to
work
with them
reports from the ground show little
desire for cooperation the taliban
blocking access for afghans trying to
reach the kabul airport and tearing up
their paperwork secretary of state
anthony blinken doing more damage
control today
there could be other americans in
afghanistan who never enrolled with the
embassy who ignored public evacuation
notices and have not yet identified
themselves to us
we've also found that
many people who contact us and identify
themselves as american citizens
including by filling out and submitting
repatriation assistance forms
are not in fact us citizens something
that can take some time to verify
some americans may choose to stay in
afghanistan
some who are enrolled and some who are
not
this effort does not end on august 31st
it will continue
uh for as long as it takes to help get
people out of afghanistan who wish to
leave but we can rest easy everyone now
the kinder gentler taliban is vowing to
tackle climate change a member of the
group's cultural commission talking to
newsweek quote we believe the world has
a unique opportunity of approachment is
that his head and coming together to
tackle the challenges not only facing us
but the entire humanity these challenges
ranging from world security and climate
change need the collective efforts
somebody went to college of all and
cannot be achieved if we exclude or
ignore an entire people who have been
devastated by imposed wars for the past
four decades wow sounds like someone's
aiming for a prime time gig on cnn
so uh dana grana thundberg must be
thrilled she might have been that yeah i
don't know the taliban is going to focus
on climate change if you want to be
accepted by the world community you
don't want your funds to be cut off from
the world you want the world bank to pay
attention to you you want some countries
to
lessen sanctions there's a great way to
their heart and they know exactly what
it is it is through climate change i
mean they probably looked on social
media like how would you trend on social
media oh you just say you're for climate
change right they're also going to
assign echo credit scores
to people right now the help program
that's very progressive like what a
interesting idea what is their carbon
footprint i mean don't they just write
those they want to be back in the 7th
century yes as far as i know there
weren't a lot i mean the methane issue
was a problem back then um i just want
to mention one other thing so
the administration is very mad about the
media coverage that they're getting yeah
okay fine i get it people complain but i
saw something today that made me uh want
to repeat it and so i didn't write this
but basically it said you don't get to
sink the ship and then brag about the
lifeboats but that is what we've been
seeing for the last several days
yesterday the united states and the uk
both called special sessions of their
legislative bodies the uk basically had
a conversation about how are we going to
protect and extract our citizens from
afghanistan to bring them home and the
united states special session was about
how can we add 5 trillion dollars of
domestic spending to this agenda
and then afghanistan was just an
afterthought yeah
insane jessica what do you have to say
to this
this is on you
yes
i'm calling all the shots in dc from my
studio here uh a couple of things the
savvy with which
dictators terrorists etc can play the
propaganda game it shouldn't be stunning
to us anymore but it is you think that
you're listening to like when putin sits
down for an interview or lavrov sits
down and they know every buzzword xi
jinping right like they know exactly
how
to trigger us to use a favorite woke
word that way um so i think it's really
interesting especially since we heard
that the world bank is going to be
withholding funds from them now that
they're not a normal country in their
terrorist organization run land one
thing that i did think was positive out
of secretary blinken's briefing is we
actually got some numbers about how many
americans were in afghanistan and how
many have been evacuated so he said that
there were 6 000 americans who had left
since august 14th
oh sorry 6k americans registered august
14th 4 500 evacuated since he believes
there to be less than a thousand
uh still in the country and i thought
the idea of people who do want to keep
staying there it was interesting like i
can't imagine at this moment being like
hey no i'm gonna i'm gonna wait this one
out and i get it there are jewel
nationals there um so it'll be
interesting to see
where that goes but with the 82 000
evacuees a lot of the people are getting
out obviously foreign nationals but a
lot of afghans are getting to other
places they're going to qatar they're
getting to western europe and and those
all seem to be positives yeah you know
um
there's a weird thing degan
is it as american as our governments
keeps pushing its way towards woke-ism
there is basically no way to deal with
something like afghanistan because we
lose the options that awoke being a woe
country would not allow you to do in a
weird way the taliban is going to be
china's problem and china's going to
have no problem
dealing with them
right
exactly it's like will
if the taliban agrees to turn their head
away from the uyghurs hey we'll give you
you know you let us operate as a terror
organization we'll give you mining
rights to our rare earth minerals i mean
our rare earth metals
we we need the money you've got you
would they again that it's just a
tolerance of one another and that
i i coined i was writing this today uh
the biden doctrine is empower our
enemies embolden evil
betray and abandon our allies
america on our ass
uh
but it goes to that point so they bite
administration with the taliban has rec
treated it as the de facto government
from all along recognizing it elevating
it legitimizing it trusting it going
back to 2013 when obama and biden
provided a diplomatic presence in doha
qatar for the taliban but then you throw
in they abandoned the afghan security
forces left a power vacuum you know
al qaeda is
ascendant now 15 province since it's in
but also remember
why is al qaeda a concern now you know
they had bioweapons labs 20 years ago
you don't think that they've looked at
china and what's gone on with the wuhan
virus killing four and a half million
people around the globe that's a
possibility and then our allies in
europe are apoplectic
uh one more thing ron klain the chief of
staff in the white house he needs to get
off twitter he is
retweeting the hack
how can he hack gas bags like the worst
of the worst like jennifer rubin at the
washington post he's like retweeting her
constantly like being portrayed by kevin
spacey in a tv movie wasn't bad enough
you got to check it out because it's
i mean no wonder biden goes out and
talks about build up better yesterday
yeah all right jesse is it time for gas
greg's artificial stance what is it all
right i believe that afghanistan is joe
biden's north korea think about what
trump tried to do
is not is to convince uh kim jong-un we
don't we're not interested in defeating
you we just want you out of our lives
could you argue that this is what joe
biden is doing north korea is still
there but the psychological the
psychological physical the physical
tension has decreased because trump
trump basically said we're not
interested and so he kind of but he put
north korea you you are now china's
problem is that what joe is doing with
afghanistan we won't have
hostages in north korea for the rest of
joe biden's term good point that's why
this was an artificial stance
i don't really believe it
well that was an official retort to your
artificial stance joe biden chose a
hostage crisis
he thought that that was the best option
he said we're not going to extend the
deadline he says we're not going to do
search and rescue so this is going to
dog joe biden for the rest of his term
jimmy carter only had a year of a
hostage crisis
joe biden's going to have three years
of a hostage crisis i i don't see how he
survives this now tactically what is
this the costliest military blunder in
united states history pearl harbor they
destroyed the pacific fleet i don't know
if you adjust that for inflation if that
matches the 82 billion in u.s hardware
we gave to the taliban what the most
embarrassing custer's last stand
little bighorn yeah you're going to have
pigs
the alamo i mean the the death toll's
not the same but in terms of a tactical
humiliation this ranks right up there
with all of them
and now he's kind of blaming the
americans that are still there for not
getting rescued oh that you didn't
register at the embassy no one registers
at the embassy
or is you know we're going to bring back
everybody that wants to leave
who wants to stay
under taliban rule
and now he's going out and he wants
credit this is the fastest airlift this
is the greatest retreat ever
um you know he's thanking the taliban
for letting americans get to the airport
americans are getting beaten on the way
to the airport so i don't see how this
shakes out right now i mean you say what
you want about trump at least trump
killed terrorists joe biden takes orders
from terrorists there you go that's the
money quote
took him a while to get there though
anyway coming up democrats in panic mode
is biden craters in the polls
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else